[Music]
[Applause]
so here it is you can check I'm short
I'm French
okay we're putting a strong French
accent so that's going to be clear in a
moment maybe a so bearing sword and
something you all know about and I
suspect many of you give something to
the people of Haiti this here and is
something else that I believe in the
back of your mind you also know this
every day
25,000 children die of entirely
preventable causes that's a Haiti
earthquake every eight days and I
suspect many of you probably gave
something to have that problem as well
but somehow it doesn't happen with the
same intensity so why is that well
here's a sort experiment for you imagine
you have a few million dollars that
you've raised maybe you have a
politician in a developing country then
you have a budget to spend you want to
spend it on the poor how do you go about
it do you believe the people who tell
you that all we need to do it to spend
money that we know how to eradicate
poverty we just need to do more well you
believe the people who tell you that aid
is not going to help on the country it
might hurt it might exacerbate
corruption dependence etc maybe you turn
to the Past after all we have spent
billions of dollars on aid maybe you
look at the person see that has it done
any good and sadly we don't know and
wash the food we will never know and the
reason is that take Africa for example I
Ferguson we got a lot of aid these are
the blue bars and the GDP and Africa is
not making much progress okay fine how
do you know what would have happened
without the aid maybe would have been
much worse
or maybe would have been much better I
have no idea we don't know what the
counterfactual is there's only one
Africa so what do you do you give the
aid and hope and pray that something
comes out of it how do you focus on your
everyday life and let the earthquake
every eight days continue to
happen the thing is if we don't know
whether we are doing any good we're not
any better than the medieval doctors and
their leeches sometimes the patient gets
better sometimes the patient die is it
delicious it is something years we don't
know so here are some other questions
there are smaller questions but they are
not that smooth immunization that's the
cheapest way to save a child's life and
the one I spend a lot of money on it the
GAVI in the gates foundation of its
pledging a lot of money towards it and
developing countries themselves have
been doing a lot of effort and yet every
year at least 25 million children do not
get the immunization they should get so
this is what you call a last mile
problem the technology is there the
infrastructure is there and yet it
doesn't happen so you have your million
how do you use your million to solve
this place my problem and here's another
question
Malaya Mya kills almost 900,000 people
every year most of them in sub-saharan
Africa most of them under five in fact
that is the leading cause of under-five
mortality so we already know how to cure
malaria but some people come to you and
say you have your Millions how about bed
nets but nets are very cheap for ten
dollars we can manufacture and sheep and
insecticide-treated bed nets and you can
teach someone to use them and not only
they protect the people who sleep under
them but they have these great contagion
benefits if half of a community sleeps
under the net the other half also
benefit because the contagion of the
disease spread and yet only a quarter of
kids at risk sleep and our net society
should be willing to go out and
subsidize the net give them for free for
that matter pay people to use them
because of those contagion benefits
we're not so fast there other people if
you give the nets for free people are
not going to value them they are not
going to use them at least they are not
going to use them as bad nets maybe as
fishing nets so what do you do to give
the nets for free to maximize coverage
or do you make people pay
in order to make sure that they really
value them how do you know and a third
question education maybe that's the
solution maybe we should send kids to
school but how do you do that do you
hire teacher do you build more schools
do you provide school lunch how do you
know so here's the thing I cannot answer
the big question whether it did any good
or not
but these three questions I can answer
them it's not the Middle Ages anymore
it's a 21st century and in the 20th
century randomized control trials I've
revolutionized medicine by allowing us
to distinguish between drugs that work
and drugs that don't work and you can do
the same randomized control trial for
social policy you can pull social
innovation to the same rigorous
scientific test that we use for drugs
and in this way you can take the
guesswork out of policymaking by knowing
what works what doesn't work and why and
I'll give you some example with those
three questions so I start with
immunization here's what they put
district what is that beautiful well
when I started working there about 1% of
children were fully immunized that's bad
but there are places like that now it's
not because the vaccines are not there
they are there and they are free and
it's not because parents do not care
about their kids the same shara that is
not immunized against measles if they do
get measles parents will spend thousands
of rupees to help them so you get these
empty village sub centers and card at
hospitals so what's the problem well
part of the problem Shirley's people do
not fully understand after all in this
country as well all sorts of myths and
misconceptions go around immunization so
if that's the case that's difficult
because PAP situation is really
difficult but maybe there is another
problem as well it's going from
intention to action imagine your mother
in Odaiba district understand you have
to walk a few kilometres to get your
kids immunized maybe when you get there
what you find is this the sub center is
closed so you have to come back and you
are so busy and you have
many other things to do you will always
tend to postpone and postpone and
eventually it gets too late well if
that's the problem then that's much
easier because a we can make it easy and
B we can maybe give people a reason to
act today rather than wait t two more so
these are simple ideas but we didn't
know so let's try them so what we did is
we did a randomized control trial in
hundred and thirty-four villages in a
Depot districts so in the blue dots are
selected randomly we made it easy I tell
you how in a moment in the red dots we
made it easy and gave people a reason to
act now the white dots are comparisons
nothing changed so will you make it easy
by organizing this monthly camp where
people can get your kids immunized and
then you make it easy and give a reason
to act now by adding a kilo of lentils
for each immunization now a kilo of land
here is tiny it's never going to
convince anybody to do something that
they don't want to do on the other hand
if your problem is you tend to postpone
then it might give you a reason to act
today rather than later so what do we
find well beforehand everything is the
same that's the beauty of randomization
after a while the camp just having the
camp increasing munitions from 6% to 17%
that's full immunization that's not bad
it's a good improvement add the lentils
and uh-2 38% so here is you got your
answer make it easy and give a kilo of
lentils you multiply munition rate by 6
now you might seem well but it's not
sustainable we cannot keep giving lentil
to people well it turns out it's own
economics because it is cheaper to give
lentils than not to give them since you
have to pay for the nerves anyway the
cost per immunization and the being
cheaper if you give incentives than if
you don't
how about bed nets should you give them
for free or should you ask people to pay
for them so the answer hinges on the
answer to three simple question one is
if people must pay for bed net are they
going to purchase them the second one is
if I give the net for free are people
going to use them and the third one is
do free bed nets discourage future
purchase that someone is important
because if we sink people get used to
handouts it might destroy markets to
distribute free bed nets now this is a
debate that has generated a lot of
emotion and angry rhetoric it's more
ideological than practical but it turns
out these are easy question we can know
the answer to this question we can just
run an experiment and many experiments
have been run and they all have the same
result so I'm just going to talk to you
about one and this one that was in Kenya
they went around and distributed to
people vouchers discount vouchers so
people could with a voucher could get
the bed net in the local pharmacy and
some people get hundred percent discount
and some people get twenty percent
discount and some people get 50%
discount etc and now we can see what
happens so how about the purchasing well
what you can see is that when people
have to pay for the bed nets the
coverage rate really falls down a lot so
even with partial subsidy three dollars
is still not the full cost of a bed nets
and now you only have twenty percent of
people with the bed nets you lose the
hand immunity that's not great second
thing is how about the youth well the
good news is people if they other bed
nets will use the badness regardless of
how they got it if they get it for free
they use it if they have to pay for it
the user how about the long term in the
long term people who got the free bed
nets
one year later were offered the option
to purchase a bed net at $2 and people
who got the free one are actually more
likely to purchase the second one then
people who didn't get a free one so
people do not get used to handouts they
get used to nets maybe we need to give
them a little bit more credit so as for
bed nets so you would sing right that's
great you know how to immunize kids you
know what to give bed nets but what
politicians need is a range of options
they need to know out of all the things
I could do what is the best way to
achieve my goals so suppose your goal is
to get kids into school it's so many
things you could do you could pay for a
uniform you could eliminate fees
you could build a tree and you could
give girls sanitary pads etc etc so
what's the best
all right some level we think all of
these things should work so is that
sufficient like if we think they should
work intuitively should we go for them
well in business are certainly not the
way we would go about it
consider for example transporting goods
before the canals were invented in
Britain before the Industrial Revolution
good used to go on horse carts and then
cannon rack built and with the same
Horseman the same horse you could carry
ten times as much cargo so should they
have continued to carry the goods on the
horse gaps on the ground that they would
eventually get there well if that had
been the case there would have been no
Industrial Revolution so why shouldn't
we do the same with social policy in
technology we spend so much time
experimenting fine-tuning getting the
absolute cheapest way to do something so
why aren't we doing that with social
policy well with experiments what you
can do is answer a simple question
suppose you have hundred dollars to
spend on various intervention how many
extra years of education do you get for
your hundred dollars now I'm going to
show you what we get with a values
education intervention so the first one
now if you want the usual suspect higher
teachers school meals school uniform
scholarships that's not bad for your
hundred dollars you get between one and
three extra years of education things
that don't work so well is bribing
parents just because so many kids are
already going to school that you end up
spending a lot of money and here are the
more surprising result tell people the
benefits of education that's very cheap
to do so for every hundred dollars we
spend doing that we get 40 extra years
of education and in places where they
are worms intestinal worms here the kids
of their worms and for every hundred
dollars you get almost 30 extra years of
education so these are not your
intuition this is not what people would
have gone for and yet these are the
programs that work we need that kind of
information we need more of it and we
need to guide policy so now I started
from the big problem and I couldn't
answer it and I cut it into small
questions and I have the answer to these
smaller questions and they are good
scientific ha best answers so let's go
back to Haiti for a moment in Haiti
about 200,000 people died actually a bit
more by the latest estimate and the
response of the world was great two
billion dollars got pled just last month
so that's about $10,000 per death that
doesn't sound that much when you think
about it
but if we were willing to spend $10,000
for every child under five who died that
would be 90 billion per year just for
that problem
and yet it doesn't happen so why is that
I think one part of the problem is that
in Haiti although the problem is huge
somehow we understand it it's localized
give your money to doctor Without
Borders you give your money to partner
in health and they'll send in the doctor
understanding the lumber and then
helicopter things out and in and the
problem of poverty is not like that so
first it's mostly invisible so don't
it's huge and third we don't know
whether we are doing the right thing
there is no silver bullet
you cannot helicopter people out of
poverty and that's very frustrating but
look what we just did today I give you
three simple answers to three questions
give lentils to immunize people provide
free bed nets you want to learn with
immunization or bed net you can save a
life for $300 per life saved with
deworming you can get an extra year of
Education for three dollars so we cannot
eradicate poverty just yet we can get
started and maybe we get started small
with things that we know are effective
here's an example of how this can be
powerful deworming ones have a little
bit of problem grabbing the headline
they are not beautiful and don't kill
anybody
and yet when the young global leader in
Davos showed the numbers I gave you
they started deworm the world and thanks
to you on the world and the efforts of
many country governments and foundation
20 million school-age children continue
on in 2009 so this evidence is powerful
it can prompt action so we should get
started now
now it's not going to be easy
it's a very slow process you have to
keep experimenting and sometimes
ideology has to be calmed by
practicality and sometimes what works
somewhere else and work elsewhere so
it's a slow process but there is no
other way this economics I'm proposing
it's like 20th century medicine it's a
slow deliberative process of discovery
there is no miracle cure but modern
medicine is saving millions of lives
every year and we can do the same thing
and now maybe we can go back to the
bigger question that I started with at
the beginning I cannot tell you whether
the aid we have spent in the past has
made a difference but can we come back
here in 13 years and say what we have
done it really prompted a change for the
better I believe we can and I hope we
will thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Sharon
that's video on the human Network Cisco
welcome to the human Network